en Chile las elecciones para elegir a
las 50 nuevas personas encargadas de
escribir un nuevo texto constitucional
en un segundo intento por reemplazar la
carta magnada de la dictadura de Augusto
pinoche se saldó con una amplia mayoría
de los partidos de derecha el
ultraconservador partido republicano
obtuvo la mayor cantidad de votos que ha
registrado un solo partido en las
últimas décadas y obtuvo por sí mismo
suficientes escaños como para bloquear
cualquier nueva Norma constitucional si
se alinea a la derecha del expresidente
Sebastián Piñera tienen entre ambos la
mayoría suficiente como para escribir
por sí solos el nuevo texto
constitucional el presidente borich
felicitó a los republicanos pero les
pidió no cometer los mismos errores que
nosotros cometimos en el proceso
anterior para conseguir un texto
constitucional que sea el del gusto de
todos y que probablemente sea aprobado
en un plebiscito de salida eso en unas
elecciones marcadas por el voto
obligatorio donde concurrieron a las
urnas 12 millones de los 15 millones de
chilenos convocados también
marcadas por una alta tasa de votos
nulos más de dos millones de personas
anularon su voto es decir casi el 17% de
los que acudieron a votar mientras que
un 4,5% de los que lo hicieron lo
hicieron en blanco el total más del 21%
de los que acudieron a las urnas ayer
votaron en